moving into the the most excellent
competition that is hopefully going to
crown by the end of the day a big winner
and it's a fairly intensive process that
will last the next five or six hours and
we're super excited to kick it off we
have a very special guest here today who
will be overseeing part and parcel of
the of this competition
her name is Jeanette Armstrong she's a
registered patent attorney and as a
director of department of energy's
technology transitions office
Armstrong coordinates technology
transition efforts across department
backed
efforts national laboratories research
facilities and program offices as well
as oversees the energy investor center
and technology commercialization fund
she also advises energy secretary Rick
Perry on technology transfer and
commercialization matters
Armstrong holds a bachelor's degree in
electrical engineering from Carnegie
Mellon University yay
and an MBA from Long Island University
in a JD from Rutgers without further ado
I'd like to welcome Jeannette who's
gonna give us some comments and we will
start this process thank you for coming
[Applause]
well welcome to the clean tech
University a price competition for the
Allegheny region it's sponsored by US
Department of Energy and this
competition is actually one of eight
regional competitions nationwide that
will provide $50,000 prize I'm happy to
be here
as jr. announced I am currently director
of the office of tech transitions at
Department of Energy
and before I start I thought I'll give
you a very quick snapshot of what do he
does and what officer tech transition
does at the goe
do you conducts basic research and a PI
research in diverse fields very diverse
fields from nuclear physics to
environmental science to batteries
nuclear weapons renewable energy super
competing for example and goe conducts
these these research through a network
of 17 National Labs you might recognize
some of the names for example Sandia
Lawrence a little more Los Alamos argon
for example so do invest very heavily in
our D basic and Applied as I mentioned
before and do a research accounts for
40% of DOA expenditures which which is
over 30 billion dollars per year so
within the OEE I head up the office
office of technology transitions which
is ot typical OTT it's a relatively new
office it was established in 2015 and we
oversee and expand commercial impact of
the investment that we make in in Rd at
the OEE so our goal is to improve
and maximize accessibility of the
National Labs to to increase the
partnership between the industry and
what's going on at the laboratories our
office responsibly extends over do iya
programs 17 laboratories and other
research and facilities that's located
throughout the country so overview of
the competition teams there are 44
states represented here today
Pennsylvania Ohio West Virginia and
Maryland a top teams from this regional
competition will go to the national
competition and have an opportunity with
even more prizes not only from the power
of energy for Department of Defense as
well winning teams will also receive
additional business development and
commercialization training and other
education opportunities
this may sound may not sound very
important but we have found that the
commercialization training it is
actually very important as part of our
R&D because you can have the greatest
innovation but if you cannot mark it in
and commercialize and put it in a format
that's that's accessible and interesting
to to the marketplace you cannot promote
your amazing innovation so the details
of the competition there are three parts
first part which you will begin shortly
is a one-minute elevator pitches these
pictures will along with there will be e
poster sessions starting at 3:45 in the
Danforth room which will be selected as
fan-favorite so in addition to three
finalists there will be another winner
selected called fan favorite so audience
can participate in selecting these
another team for from the judging
process this is a link
which can type into any electronic
device that you will have access to the
form to pick your pick your team that
you like best and then the top three
teams will make their ten minute pitches
finals back in this room at 5:00 p.m. so
with that I like to invite our first
team to come up and make their long run
minute speech okay I've been fascinated
by a renewable energy ever since I lived
in the highlands of Guatemala when I
came back to the United States I had the
opportunity to visit a wind farm and was
kind of struck by the sheer size of the
blades I mean one blade spans the length
of an entire football field and I was
wondering how do these guys these
operators know when a blade is wearing
down or when it sustained damage and I
was surprised to find out that a couple
of times a year they'll send people up
into the turbines and they have to
rappel down the blade and physically
monitor the wind turbine blade to check
for damage and I thought there's got to
be a better way in this day and age now
remote sensing allows engineers safely
on the ground to collect data multiple
times a day an active charge our
technology takes that one step further
by removing the need for batteries so
that you can install the sensor inside
of the turbine and collect data without
any shutdowns of the turbine generation
thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
my name is Prince Ghosh and I'm the
founder and CEO of bamboo labs we're a
startup spun out of research conducted
at Case Western Reserve University in
Cleveland Ohio focused on
commercializing our dielectric barrier
discharged plasma actuator technology
essentially what we've created is a thin
flexible solid-state electrode that can
be applied in the form of a tape right
to the surface of a wind turbine blade
when activated our electrodes generate a
thin layer of non thermal plasma over
the surface of the blade and control the
air flowing around it with the series of
electric fields this yields and increase
in aerodynamic efficiency and overall
power output of the turbine by about
four percent we've tested benchtop scale
tests at Case Western Reserve and are
partnered with NASA Glenn Research
Center in Cleveland Ohio to conduct
full-scale wind tunnel testing I have a
vision that one day every turbine in
America is gonna have our technology on
it pushing us one step closer to
offsetting the effects of fossil fuels
thank you so much for your time
[Applause]
good afternoon i'm nathaniel mclean from
Coppin State University have you ever
been caught out 3% in today's day and
age we have a constant need to charge
our portable devices but the problem is
all these solutions are either bulky
expensive our environmentally unfriendly
our Coppin State University they sold a
study solar tech team is using
technology that can be integrated into
backpacks using natural days to generate
power from sunlight we're currently
working with touring companies to get
the technology into your backpack so
that you can charge on the go we're
hoping to reach out to the some 3,000
students at Coppin State University and
expand to about 400,000 students in
Maryland to given them the power to
charge on the go giving you an
affordable efficient energy friendly
environmentally friendly option that you
can use on the go and stay in fashion
thank you very much Coppin State
University
[Applause]
what if I told you that this Apple had
the potential to be so much more than
just trash what if I told you that we
had a system that could help solve this
160 billion dollar food waste problem
our sewer system is the first of its
kind that is easily deployable and can
help restaurants profit off of two
different types of revenue streams the
first is the clean energy that we can
produce from the third their food waste
and the second is the fertilizer that we
can give back to the communities we have
already raised over $100,000 within one
year and have created Pittsburgh's first
portable farming system additionally we
are launching our first prototype of our
anaerobic digestion system in May and
have been receiving interest from
companies internationally we're ecotone
renewables we are here to close the food
loop and we are creating a system thank
you
[Applause]
unfortunately the company designed ice
it's actually a fairly painful process
they get out of a scientist
ask them to analyze spreadsheets and
switching some data to come up with a
new design that's enough and keep
utilizing this for possibly hundreds of
iterations until they find something
that satisfies their needs and this is
the high-pressure situation to be in
especially if you know that fast
innovation and discovery is what defines
a success and here's where becoming at
experiment the book of machine learning
experts who have developed a platform we
can choose better experiments to suit
your needs and make this parallel
process more efficient and well
traditionally people tend to use
software as a service or platforms a
service as a business business model for
services like this our goal is to
develop a platform to develop patent and
[Applause]
hi we are grid fruit from Carnegie
Mellon in the US there are more than
200,000 grocery stores and they operate
on razor thin profit margins around one
percent that means today they're
suffering as Amazon takes more and more
market share the supermarket's
refrigerators alone take up to 20
percent of their potential profits these
refrigerators are gathering data from
different components but that data stays
separate and never sees the light of day
at grid fruit we have an AI platform
that takes this data collects it and
applies Rai learning algorithms to
provide the customers with optimal
temperature set points and customize
tailored maintenance recommendations to
reduce their costs by up to 15%
now these customers are generating over
a trillion dollars in revenue every year
and our market is eight billion dollars
per year we have one pilot going to in
the works we're bringing AI to your
grocery store thank you imagine you're
driving your shiny new electric vehicle
cruising across Allegheny County but
then when you see those red flashing
danger lights flashing across your
dashboard no battery understandably
you'll be anxious you want to find the
next available charging station but
they're just not enough not one that's
certainly available to your vehicle's
remaining range what do you do this is
where we bridge the gap hi my name is
Ashwin and I'm from our new tricity with
Carnegie Mellon University we work with
residential small commercial locations
and electric vehicle drivers in
providing affordable fast charging
equipment that is compatible with any
electric vehicle in today's market we
are assuring economy business model that
enables host:2 to basically share their
charges for any of the electric vehicle
to come and charge we are electricity
and we make sure that your electric
vehicle travel is a lot less anxious
thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon good afternoon there we
go okay so my name is David Smith I'm
here representing West for University
and square line power
scoreline powers and mission has brought
safe durable solutions to the modern
electrical problems we have this day
using that doing inductive charging
power using wireless power in our first
application we look to target the 30,000
new internet cafes I've been open the
last 15 years with that in using
furniture to charge the laptops and cell
phones that you all use and I use while
I sit there and not buy anything in the
coffee shops to make it so that every 30
minutes you charge per 50 cents or $1 or
something like that to be able to make
they have recurring cash flows whenever
it comes to the business second phase is
to move on to Drouin charging so thank
you the law enforcement can make it so
that the cutoff for the unplugging of
the drones end up so that they save
countless time for emergencies thank you
very much
[Applause]
poop is a serious problem and it's an
especially big problem when it comes to
water conservation energy and health the
standard toilet uses six liters per
flush and when that scales up that means
that we're flushing away 100 billion
litres of water every day reducing the
toilets water footprint would lead to
lower energy bills lower water bills and
less wasted water but conventional
toilet surfaces need water to prevent
fouling and foul odors and bacteria
accumulation so to address to lower the
water footprint of a toilet while also
maintaining a clean toilet experience
we've developed a sprayable surface
coating that can repel liquids solid
waste and also bacteria any residue left
behind on our surface can be washed away
with 90 percent less water than a
conventional toilet surface our ultimate
goal is to revolutionize the way that
waste is managed and perhaps with a
coating like ours
one day toilets will be able to keep
themselves clean while also reducing
their environmental impact thank you
[Applause]
conventional energy sources are dying
causes and have left in their wake
pressing environmental health issues and
expensive removals of hazardous waste to
combat these we propose the advancement
of a new sector of renewable energy
plant generated electricity we give you
then charge an idea that employs the
multi-faceted applications of the
generation of electricity through plants
with carbon electrodes and a power
harvester attached to a constructed
array of plants we can now use the very
nature we are trying to preserve to
supplement our electricity needs 24/7 in
particular our latest innovative focus
agem charge involves an electricity
producing green wall the utilization of
revolutionary all inclusive technology
safeguarding our power and our earth
this is in charge
thank you hello my name is Tim I am from
HEC the green hawks compact composter
the problem that we have today is many
residential areas produce about six
about four pounds of compostable waste
each day but most residential areas do
not have composters that can meet their
demands especially ones that are
automatic they're not there our goal at
HCC green Hawks is to create a composter
that can man connect can automatically
biodegrade the matter quicker and faster
without the need for manual labor of
having to continuously turn it and add
water this will automatically do all
this for you thank you
[Applause]
thank you all the team members thank you
for coming up just figuring out what you
have to say in one minute that's that's
really difficult so now audience please
remember to vote for your favorite team
so they can another team can have have
an award also at 3:45 is when the poster
session is please this is way too short
for you to figure out learn more about
what's going on with its great great
innovation have been discussed here
please start by at 3:45 Danford room
which is just past the festive place
that are on this floor to talk to the
team members and and ask about the
innovations and please return here at 5
o'clock to see who won the $50,000 award
thank you Harris
[Applause]